sag mir doch das war ja es ist wahr ich
bin der sagt einen ring tragen ich würde
gern in seinem gehirn worden wenn sie
sich an sie die admira nachdem ich
[Applaus]
constantin hat ja lange letzter gedreht
und dieser film könnte eigentlich jetzt
heißen erst logo also diese das heißt
die verführten auf deutsch aber dieser
film könnte eigentlich auch la grande
tristesse die große traurigkeit denn
berlusconi wird gezeichnet als einander
eigentlich am ende ist der dieses ganze
show gebaren jahre lang gepflegt hat und
sich als grosser macho stilisiert hat
und es bleibt nicht übrig als leere
erschöpfung dekadenz das nicht langsam
museum für mich jetzt noch nicht die
tore
der film ist im prinzip als triptychon
gebaut wir haben eine lange strecke in
dem wir einen menschen sehen der
politische ambitionen hat und bei des
coni herankommen möchte indem er ihm
showgirls zuführt das macht den ersten
drittel des films aus films also sehr
sehr lange auf berlusconi warten dann
kommt berlusconi sehr viel show sehr
viel party und danach werden die beiden
dinge wieder so miteinander
zusammengeführt das heißt man braucht
einen sehr langen atem um den film sich
anzuschauen
ich denke toni servillo gibt eine sehr
sehr gute figur ab als berlusconi mit
schwarzem nach hinten gewählten total
künstlich aussehenden haaren stark
geschminkt sehr verzweifelt der mann ist
eine einzige maske und bemerkt wirklich
wie seine figur daran leide immer in
dieser maskenhaftigkeit stecken zu
bleiben und nie irgendwie eigentlich zu
sein
insofern ist da für mich ohne sympathie
für berlusconi ja sehr sehr böse sehr
sehr erbarmungslos aber hat dann auch
wieder momente in denen man berlusconi
tatsächlich ein bisschen bemitleidet auf
meine frage du tust mir leid du und
deine freunde auch ihr seid die figuren
von total an da ja mit geld aus der
matratze und abwägen kleinen scherzen
denn die zunge aus dem maul hängt wenn
sie ein foto von nacken tänzerin sehen
genau das seit ihr gestriger alte
witzfiguren die bloß so tun als ob sie
moderne wäre dieser film fühlt sich im
prinzip nahtlos ein in den kinos werk er
hat sich schon mit julian bewerb befasst
in evivo er hat sich jetzt jüngst
befassten mit dem papst in einer serie
mit julian cope also es geht um macht
und korruption und dekadenz und dass
italien das irgendwie verrottet ist und
nicht auf die beine kommt und das ist
schon ein dauerthema von ihm dass er
hier jetzt neu beleuchtet
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
korrekt ist
die sollen die no vir regisseur schreibt
auch im vorspann dass es mit fiktionalen
elementen arbeitet aber natürlich reale
figuren da verarbeitet sind
die allerdings mit erfundenen figuren
interagieren insofern ist es eine mich
ein mix eine mischung aus dachten und
tatsächlich soll dieses sechs senatoren
überzeugen
jeder der sich für politik interessiert
und sich fragt wie demagogen populisten
sich an der macht halten könnte und was
diese menschen möglicherweise treiben
könnte also jeder in der sich für die
psychologie eine solchen führers
anführers politischen charismatikers
interessierten der kann in diesem film
wirklich gefallen finden so habe ich
diese junge machen in dem zimmer
[Musik]
aber jetzt bin ich es nicht mehr